I want to run through a scenario with
you right now with a Strategic Homeland
division doesn't exist
what I'm wanting to see is how much has
the division actually managed to achieve
in curving the outcome of the events
that have played out
understandably the story is still
running its path so in this alternate
timeline we're going to put a Line in
the Sand and see how different things
could be up until this point in the
story
what will it take to save what remains
as we know the origins of the shd stem
all the way back from World War II but
the true inspiration came from a couple
of real world events that took place
more recently in 2001 a high-level
simulation called operation dark winter
was conducted by federal agencies to
test the nation's ability to respond to
a widespread bioterrorist attack the
results were eye-opening showing that
the nation across all levels was
completely unprepared then on September
11th of the same year a terrorist attack
would be responsible for the death of
thousands of Americans
this would lead to President George W
bush signing the National Security
Presidential Directive 51 on the 4th of
May 2007 a mandate that allows executive
power to direct government procedures in
the event of a catastrophic emergency
now in this timeline this still happened
with one small difference the shd was
never established in response to these
events
first wave of Agents were activated
shortly after the green poison outbreak
occurred in Manhattan New York their
mission was to support the jtf in
containing the widespread Anarchy that
was unfolding throughout the center of
Manhattan but after the jtf pulled out
leaving the agents to fend for
themselves the majority of the first
wave went MIA
this was the event that had the second
wave activated whoever time would find
out what actually happened to the first
wave and that over the coming months
these would be the greatest foe
however in this timeline the division
agents would never be activated and
never come to the aid of the jtf the jtf
would still be forced to pull out of the
area that would later be known as the
dark Zone but no one would be left
behind I mean other than the civilians
of course except without the agents the
goings-on within the dark Zone would be
left relatively unchecked allowing the
growing hostile presence within to find
their own foothold establishing solid
territories while also fighting for
control mostly uninterrupted by
government forces any innocent civilians
would undoubtedly be swallowed up by the
violence that would follow as rival
factions fight it out
in our timeline the jtf has been pushed
so far back that they are barely a force
that could be considered a threat by
even the weakest of hostile factions
however without the support of the
division it's unlikely that they would
still exist in any sort of capacity
notable figures like Jessica candle all
roads and Roy Benitez were integral to
the jtf setting up a foothold in New
York City without the agents the jtf may
never have been able to rescue them
over the last 10 months or so the
division has been responsible for
picking apart most hostile groups and
eliminating their leadership
for some this has led to the group
falling apart being absorbed into
another faction or the mantle of
responsibility being shifted on to the
second in command
with the letter this would often lead to
a difference in structure organization
and goals in turn creating infighting
due to the number of Personnel in the
group who no longer feel they are
heading in the same direction for the
same reasons that their founder
established the group in the first place
basically regardless of outcome the
division was responsible for crippling
the Rikers rioters cleaners lmb outcasts
hyenas and true sons while they continue
to exist after their leadership was
taken out they would never have the same
presence or strength that they once had
so how would things have played out if
there was no division
each of these groups in their respective
cities would have continued to grow in
power and territory with Little
Resistance from the jtf
however instead of the division slowing
down their progression their main
obstacle would be each other
as they come to a head the strong
affections would come out on top either
eliminating or absorbing the weaker ones
while what remains of the jtf could do
nothing but sit back and watch
in New York the Rikers and rioters lack
of structure organization and ongoing
infighting would quickly fall to the
cleaners in lmb while the cleaners are
out equipped and trained versus the lmb
this is their City they have the
passionate leadership of Joe Farrow and
they have the numbers especially as
others join their ranks either due to
the need to survive or having now
experienced similar circumstances that
had the cleaners form in the first place
there is a chance that the lmb and
cleaners will either join forces or
create a truce going forward allowing
them instead to commit resources to
spreading their influence outwards from
the city
in Washington DC the hyenas will quickly
prove to be no match for either the
outcasts or the true Sons the outcasts
and the true Sons will each carve out
large portions of the city for
themselves while the outcasts should be
absolutely no match for the true Sons
their large numbers and cult-like
organization under Emily in Shaw's
leadership will have them not only
continue to grow in number but the
unorthodox style of fighting and
ambushing the true Sun's forces will
constantly have them on the back foot
due to their history there is no chance
of any sort of alliance or peace between
these two groups
it goes without saying that if there was
no division there would be no Rogue
agents these individuals would still be
around but they wouldn't have the
Advanced Training technology or quite
the same presence it's possible that
they would have just created their own
faction but I find this unlikely as most
of the Rogues didn't know each other
outside of the division plus a large
number of them only turned Rogue because
of what happened to the first wave or
were manipulated by Aaron Keener more
likely is that the individual agents who
wanted to do something would have joined
the jtf lmb true Sons or Black Tusk
however we also wouldn't have Vitali
trinenko after the L B captured vitelli
Kina took off for them when the division
were attacking the headquarters at the
U.N building from there he would drop
him off as a trade with the Black Tusk
but not before he had vitelli create the
eclipse virus
the division would intercept this trade
and rescue the Telly but at this stage
the Delhi hasn't done anything
particularly useful since his release
so with no division there would be no
Rogues meaning no Aaron Kina no Eclipse
virus and no rogue agent Network which
has been the bulk of what the division
has been fighting up until now in fact
the L B may not have even bothered
capturing him from the Russian Embassy
if it wasn't for their alliance with
arankina vitelli may never have been
captured in the first place
but if the lmb had kept hold of them
it's hard to say what they would have
had him do
although not technically Rogue balao
also wouldn't have been around in the
same light she wouldn't have gone deep
undercover to kill President Ellis or
bring Barden Schaefer over to the other
side
while Ellis was looking to have doubts
about Natalia and Black Tusk of the
India I find it unlikely that he would
have been able to change much of what
was happening but perhaps her doing this
stop them being able to use Ellis and
activating the black box
the government in our timeline is pretty
much non-existent while I don't think
it's completely gone those who have
survived are deep in hiding far from the
events that are unfolding
the division has actually had very
little influence on this outcome so I
don't expect anything would have changed
if they weren't around
an argument could be placed on the first
mission of The Division II where agents
were able to stop the hyena attack on
the White House but I mean there are
only four or five of them I think even
the jtf could have stopped this on their
own in saying that I don't really
understand why the Black Tusk hasn't
attacked the white house yet agents or
not it would stand no chance
here is where I think the true impact of
having no agents around would be the
civilians and Innocents caught up within
the feuding these are the ones who would
suffer
settlements outside the major cities
should be fine at least for now but the
ones we are aware of with the New York
City in Washington DC these would take a
much different form
with the strong affections left
unhindered and allowed to grow far
beyond what we have witnessed in this
current timeline Supply and resources
will only become a larger part of their
survival with growing numbers and wider
territory to keep under control the need
for food and locations for the members
to rest and restock will only increase
existing settlements won't just be
eradicated they will instead be
controlled by the faction that holds
power over the area
the settlements won't be what they are
now an area of Refuge where innocence
can begin to rebuild there will be more
of a farm for the overlords who ruled
the area
as we now know the Black Tusk and
Natalia have been in the picture since
early on in the outbreak likely long
before
their invasion of Washington DC they
were keeping an eye on all of the
warring factions it was only after all
of the factions were defeated by the
division that they made their move
before then the Black Tusk were just
lurking in the shadows sabotaging and
eliminating the division agents so given
that the early operations focused on the
division and essentially waiting on them
to do the job for them how would this
have affected the way the black task
announced their presence in this
conflict
would they have waited just as long
it's more likely that they would have
invaded much earlier as the Hostile
factions who now control DC are only
getting stronger
except now they have all of their
leadership and officers intact as well
as prison Alice the antivirals and the
perfusion bioreactor
although they don't have the division or
Rogue agents to contend with groups like
The True Sons outcasts cleaners and L B
are now much stronger than we had ever
witnessed in our timeline
while I believe that the black task
would eventually come out on top they
would be looking at a long drawn-out
battle over many months especially if
some of these groups were able to join
together
obviously this is completely
hypothetical with any change like this
it's impossible to protect every outcome
my conclusion of what would have
happened had the shd never been
established is that the US wouldn't be
in a much different position than we are
in the current timeline the vast
majority of what the agents have
achieved has unintentionally assisted
the Black Tusk in their plans for
Invasion with the rest of their time
being spent on Rogue agents like Aaron
Kina and many of the Rogue cells he put
together who wouldn't have been around
in the first place if the agency didn't
exist
one major difference is that the
Innocence dotted throughout this
conflict would have had absolutely no
chance without the support of the agents
however even in the current timeline
these settlements in other groups of
Innocence are really just hanging on
there aren't enough agents left to keep
them protected and with the Black Tusk
looming it's only a matter of time
agents may have slowed the fall of the
jtf but their numbers still don't work
as any sort of deterrent to the larger
hostile groups
obviously we have no idea what is
happening around the rest of the country
and there could be a number of instances
where the division has really turned the
tide but all we have to go on is the
major events that have played out across
New York and Washington DC
one outcome has a handful of remaining
agents acting as the last hurdle for a
large well-trained and equipped Force
attempting to take control
the other outcome has the same group
going head-to-head with four other
factions
in all fairness to the division agents
their mission was to save what remains
and ensure the continuity of government
while the government seems to be mostly
lost at this point what they have
managed to do is the rescuing of
survivors and assisting the settlements
with receiving resources at least for
now
the division wasn't prepared for what
they were going to face the Hostile
takeover from a large military force
this wasn't what they were trained for
so here are my questions for you the
viewer what do you think that the
division has managed to achieve up until
now do you think the us would have been
better or worse off without them
there are so many other ways this could
have played out without the division
agents around how do you think the story
could have gone
I watch a lot of alternate history
videos and I thought this would be an
interesting concept to try out on the
division storyline there are so many
things that could be altered to change
the story outcome like what if Kina
didn't go Rogue what if the division
followed president Alice in joining the
Black Tusk would the black task lead in
the country be any worse than what we're
going through now
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this video
and I'll catch you in the next one
cheers
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]